Ob Erdbeere oder Maracuja - nicht immer stecken die Früchte auf der
Müsliriegel-Verpackung auch drin.
Sebastian Lege zeigt euch, wie mit dem
Umfruchtungstrick aus Rosinen und Äpfeln
ganz leicht unendlich viele Früchte
werden und wie ihr den Schwindel auf der
Verpackung erkennt.
Und jetzt zeige ich Ihnen,
wie man eine Rosine in eine
Erdbeere verwandelt. Voraussetzung, damit
die Rosine als Erdbeere durchgeht - sie
muss möglichst jeden Geschmack verlieren.
Dazu hat Sebastian Lege die Rosinen
mehrere Stunden in Wasser eingeweicht.
Jetzt einfach das Wasser rauspressen
und der typische Geschmack sollte weg
sein.
Der Aufwand lohnt sich, denn Erdbeeren
hätten mindestens fünfmal so viel
gekostet wie Rosinen und getrocknete
Äpfel.
Gleich wird Sebastian Lege dafür sorgen,
dass den Unterschied niemand mehr
bemerkt.
Hier sind noch ein paar getrocknete
Äpfel, die eignen sich super zum umfruchten,
weil die sind wie so kleine Schwämme. Die kann man mit allem möglichen befüllen, da
kann eine Maracuja draus werden, da kann auch
eine Orange draus werden - ist total super. Also
füllen wir noch ein bisschen auf.
Die Verwandlung - Aroma aus der Tüte sorgt
für den Geschmack, ein Extrakt aus Roter
Bete für die Farbe und zum Schluss noch
etwas Erdbeersirup.
Ohja, das sieht gut aus. Woah, das riecht..
wie 'ne Nacht im Erdbeerfeld hier.
Wahnsinn. Das muss man jetzt in dem Sirup lange
ziehen lassen, damit die Rosinen sich
schön mit dem Aroma und mit dem Sirup
vollsaugen können.
Das Ganze muss danach noch einmal
getrocknet werden, weil das muss ja dann
wieder zusammen schrumpfen, damit es später
in unseren Riegel passt. Und schon kann
Sebastian Lege seine billigen Rosinen-
und Apfelstücke als Erdbeeren verkaufen.
Nach dem Trocknen sind sie vielfältig
verwendbar.
Weil bei Obstregeln besonders gern umgefruchtet wird, zaubert auch Sebastian
Lege nun einen Erdbeer-Müsliriegel - nur
eben ohne Erdbeeren.
Jetzt noch mit billigem Maissirup
alles verkleben und ab in den Ofen zum
aushärten.
Am Ende soll ja alles stabil und
knusprig sein.
Zwei Stunden später.
Hört sich schon mal ganz gut an! Jetzt holen wir die
kleinen Freunde mal aus ihrer Form.
Na, die selbstgemachten Müsliriegel können
sich doch sehen lassen.
Der Umfruchtungstrick scheint gelungen.
Dass die rot-klebrige Fruchtmasse nicht
aus Erdbeeren besteht, das ist nicht zu
erkennen - wenn jetzt auch noch der
Geschmack stimmt? Ich würde mal sagen, das könnten wir fast ins Supermarkt-Regal legen. Bin da
super mit zufrieden. Hoffentlich schmeckts' auch nach
Erdbeere.
Hmm, ja..ein bisschen klebrig
und echt erdbeerig, das ist wahnsinn! Null Rosine, noch nicht
mal ein Ansatz von Rosine. Rosine hat ja
so ein bisschen leicht dumpfe, karamellige
Töne. Aber schmeckt wie Erdbeer'
vom Feld. Und diesen Riegel, in dem
Erdbeere nur in Form von einer kleinen
Portion Sirup steckt, könnte Sebastian
Lege jetzt als Erdbeerriegel in den
Handel bringen,
denn so machen es fast alle. Vorne drauf
die schönsten Früchte und drin stecken
doch fast nur Äpfel und Rosinen.
Das ist leider zulässig. Der Gesetzgeber
sagt, man erkennt das ja an der
Zutatenliste, also am Kleingedruckten,
aber wir meinen, dass ist ganz klar
Etikettenschwindel, weil man doch getäuscht
wird, wenn man die hochwertigen Früchte
auf der Schauseite sieht, aber dann im
Kleingedruckten diese umgefruchteten,
billigeren Früchte. Auch bei Säften
sollten Verbraucher besser zweimal
hinsehen, was sie da eigentlich kaufen.
Denn - nur weil die Verpackung Tropen-
früchte, Himbeeren oder Mango-Ananas zeigt,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass
besonders viel davon drin steckt. In
Säften finden wir auch mit Früchten sehr
viel Verbrauchertäuschung, zum Beispiel Tropical Juice, wo man denkt, also hier sind nur
Tropenfrüchte enthalten wie Ananas und
Mangos oder Maracuja und man schaut dann
hier im Kleingedruckten und sieht 50%
Apfelsaft, 35% Orangensaft - also 85
Prozent schon mal ganz andere Säfte und
auch das halten wir für
Verbrauchertäuschung,
denn hier entsteht einfach durch das
Schaubild eine andere Erwartung. Tropenfrüchte? Zusammengerechnet gerade mal 15 Prozent.
Himbeersaft? Nicht mal 8 Prozent. 16
Prozent Mango und Ananas. Von weitem sah
das alles irgendwie nach mehr aus.
Selbst, wenn der Geschmack fast nur von
Aromastoffen stammt, anstatt von der
winzigen Menge Erdbeeren, sind die
Hersteller im Recht. Solange sie die
wahren Zutaten korrekt deklarieren. Wurde mal wieder umgefruchtet? Wie so oft
hilft uns Verbrauchern nur der genaue
Blick auf die Zutatenliste.
Welche Müsliriegel esst ihr am liebsten?
Und worauf achtet ihr beim Kauf? Sagt es
uns in den Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei Clips.